-Finally, following
President Trump's indictment,
Trump and many of his allies
have been claiming
that Manhattan DA Alvin Bragg's
investigation
is funded by liberal
mega-donor George Soros.
Here to comment
is one of my writers,
Jeff Wright, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
Thank you, Seth.
Now, first of all,
when I heard all these people
mentioning George Soros,
I had no idea who he was.
I was like, "They're blaming
Trump's indictment on that dude
that wears glasses
and lied about
playing volleyball?
I thought he liked Trump."
-Oh, Jeff, that's George Santos.
-I know that now.
After looking him up on TikTok.
And it turns out George Soros
is some rich liberal billionaire
who donates
to a lot of Democrats.
And Republicans think
he's the puppet master
controlling all the strings on
all these Trump investigations.
And that is offensive.
-Because it's anti-Semitic?
-And racist.
I mean, why can't people admit
that a Black person is capable
of hatching an evil scheme
like this all by himself?
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Seth, look at all these
statements.
Ron DeSantis called Alvin Bragg
Soros-backed.
Senator Ron Johnson
called him Soros-funded.
And just look at all these times
Fox News mentioned Soros.
-George Soros funded D.A.s.
-George Soros-funded D.A.
-Soros-funded D.A.
-George Soros.
-Soros.
-I'm Soros'd out!
[ Laughter ]
Even Trump mentioned Soros
in his speech from Mar-a-Lago.
Why you got to keep
bringing Soros into this?
Let Alvin Bragg enjoy his time
in the spotlight.
-Sorry.
So you want Alvin Bragg
to get all the scrutiny
that comes with indicting Trump?
-Seth, this is
Black people's moment, okay?
Having a Black president
was great,
but letting a Black man
take down Trump,
that's the final boss level.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look, think of it
in Hollywood terms.
It's great when they let
a Black guy star in a movie.
But true equality
can't be achieved
until Black people are allowed
to play the bad guy.
Okay, forget Idris Elba
playing Bond.
Why can't I be a Bond villain?
[ Dramatic music plays ]
I see you finally
figured it out, Mr. Bond.
It is I who have been
stealing candy from children.
See, when I was a boy,
I wasn't allowed
to have candy or friends.
So now neither will the world!
[ Laughs maniacally ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm Jeff Wright.
I'm 6' feet tall
and I'm represented
by Erica Lancaster at CAA.
-Okay, Jeff, so I hear
you calling the investigation
Soros-funded is racist.
But just to be clear,
it's also anti-Semitic, right?
-Oh, hell yeah, Seth.
They ain't going to catch me on
some Kanye West [bleep].
-Alright.
That's Jeff Wright, everybody.
Give it up for Jeff Wright.
[ Cheers and applause ]